Này 2018 tháng 12, ngoại trường Trung Quốc vương yệ có phát biểu công khai lần đầu về sức mấy ngoại sao với như bàn.
Ông những mạnh, vý thu tự như bàn công khai uống hộ khả nân cánh thì quân sự vào mất nề đài loàn,
là tính nhiều sai lệ, và vừa giữa hạn công được phép trạm vào, cảnh báo Trung Quốc sẽ kiến quyết đất trả.
Ông vương yệ khẳng định, với dân Trung Quốc không bao giờ thoại hiệp về chủ quyền và tòan về lãnh thổ.
Mọi trình Trung Quốc yêu cầu Trung kiểu tôn thu của càng kết chính trị, liên quan tự đàn loàn, được kỳ trong bố phát kiệ sống phương,
đồng thời cần nhắc kỳ lần phát ngôn và hành động để tránh lộ thành công thàn.
Ông cũng hỏi tu nhảm ảm ả sửa xanh cảnh sửa cần tốt, nhảm ảnh mạnh rằng mọi đàn phái hệ cá nhân năm quyền nềm bàn,
đều phải tôn thu của càng kết định được xá lập.
Quân hệ mắc kênh Trung Quốc hiện vẫn mấy tắc, chưa xa định được thời điểm có của học đà phương của thị diễn xa,
giáu sự khách biệt quan điểm về đài loàn.